[Music]
44 seconds of logos wait four and four
equals eight was this on purpose look I
realize rabbits gotta get hyped up and
but this is way over the top
we don't even see him eat the spaghetti
also I was there no one in this bathroom
during the psych up sequence this is
like mission impossible fallout levels
of bathroom coziness and yeah someone
eventually does knock on the door but
the club is full so how did it take this
long also also this bathroom is at least
a three seater so wanted to have a lock
on the door at all bathroom was wrong on
so many levels in the first two minutes
of his big movie and proves that anyone
can look like a dope rapper if they just
cover the mic up real good with their
hands okay cool future I think you boy
got a attitude problem literally no one
disagrees with the statement the point
is sofa how many things are wrong with
this scenario first off how did rabbit
just notice this after the bathroom
scene second how did future immediately
ascertain that it is puke on rabbits
hoody third how did he get puke right
though there he went immediately to the
toilet when he got sick and finally
that's not even a king sweater it's a
king hoodie what the hell lose yourself
means you need just broke up yeah and
tell Yatta Yatta by the way it was
actually rabbit that broke up with her
and that's a plot point that's kind of
important but I guess it's not as
important as some casual artisan later
something's gonna happen what this needs
to happen now well the best way to make
that happen is for you to go on stage
and choke out right because of fear or
reasons for fear reasons think you can
manage future is putting his entire
future on rabbit and I know he's a good
rapper but this is way too much hype for
future to be futuring rip the rapper
head off
sausage do you have the cuz that'll
playboy now tell me who's fresh the
movie doesn't give nearly enough credit
to this dude here yes rabbit bails and
doesn't wrap a single line but also
let's not forget his opponents straight
correct oh wait no rhyme was actually
pretty basic
oh well which way should I go here the
line
obsolete future is so cognitively
dissonant that I want a cinema kind of
it but the fact that Mekhi Phifer is
just casually insulted by the dis is so
funny that i want to remove one ah i
can't be mad at you future also how
rabbits crew gets such primo spots for
this battle like the free world crew is
adjacent to the stage but they're still
in the audience chatter Bob and the boys
are on the king stage
it's well cooked Jesus I haven't seen a
host this openly antagonistic of a
contestant since Slumdog Millionaire in
heated contest among many contenders
including Pearl Harbor Vanilla Sky
Groundhog Day and bad boys to eight mile
ultimately one that you totally forgot
Michael Shannon was in this competition
also it's not like Jimmy's quiet when he
walks in here but his mom doesn't even
turn around to see who's coming into her
front door as she's letting someone come
in the front door okay baby
you know other than probably seeing my
exposed to asshole and Greg's balls a
few minutes ago
everything else good don't you think you
shoulda called her not first or
something phone's disconnected all right
sure cool but about the knocking I
thought she had a really good thing
going with her the ex he hates that we
barely ever see in this movie who is
portrayed is terrible yeah it really
almost made it didn't think so at least
I got a good job man I gave Eminem's
acting a huge pass when I first saw this
movie mostly because it generally kicks
ass but this performance honestly holds
up about as well as Michael Shannon's
finger in the shape of water hey Jesus
Christ if this is basically an Eminem
biopic just go ahead and actually name
the kid Haley even if she's his sister
in the movie it's past her babe however
good rabbit is at rapping on the spot
he's the opposite of that it's singing
on the spot I know it just still might a
little rabbit right everything Jimmy's
mom does in this movie feels absolutely
caked and achiness now what happened to
you last night I heard you got caught
out the people sing some damn it's only
been like six hours since the rap battle
right around here news travels quicker
than a mmm that's a fast animal that I
can use as a metaphor like a rodent
shaped animal that's super fast oh yeah
faster than a wild Marmot eight mile you
keep using that phrase I do not think
you know that I do not know what it
means no one will be seated during the
lyric writing goddamn Detroit his
portion of the movie weird thing my
college girlfriend chanted at me during
all 11 minutes of our first sexual
encounter somehow makes it into this rap
battle movie
oh come on movie everyone knows they
don't make cars in America foreplay
leading to immediate upskirting and they
say romance is dead I gotta say it is
cool here Eminem cover a Kid Rock song
this ain't cool I'm in a race he's
tapping my mom we're almost the same
mates this and a whole lot of other
sloppy rhyming gets passed off as clever
in this movie and it's annoying the
final battles clever is all
rapping prior to that in this film I
don't know man you win some of these
battles three one-third will have all
the street credit we need he's talking
about his crew right honestly I can't
even keep up with these names with the
leaders of the free world the librarians
Papa Smurf to me three balls string bean
wild Shamu Big Bertha troll Tyler the
Creator little Todd jumbo shrimp the do
mentally ill car accident more both of
you are now in casual mental health
dismissal timeout dogs now will you
hurry up with that thing go try it now
and it works rabbit fix this mother here
with a flathead screwdriver in his bare
hands I have never seen a dude with a
more postured bird flip like it seems
like em spent hours rehearsing this move
look at the position of the knuckles the
Flair of the thumb it almost resembles
art till you realize that it's literally
a few hearing your identity and
self-worth with a king area code is so
20th century yeah man witness Detroit
ever gonna come up with its own sound
thank you we interrupt this presentation
of eight-mile to bring you a very
important after-school special also
discount ghost riding the whip what's
happening on the da hood man
yo stasher man chill out and since
rabbit has the super magical mechanic
hands this would be fixed in a jiffy
this parking job see how bunny rabbit
dude come on man
so his rabbit never rapped in public
before seriously everyone knows how dope
it is but nobody's ever heard it yeah
the free one pink cheddar Bob he's
well-meaning but he is otherwise 99% cup
you need to take that white ass rap but
yours back across eight mile roll
distances did they say riously just go
from the parking lot battle to this bar
at the exact same time as the rival gang
was headed there this movie is fun but
it's more interested in placing
characters in certain specific
situations than actual plot advancement
I'm sorry people papi they'll see me in
a boat man I forgot how into central
this beef with Papa Doc was until I
watch this movie again the framing it
more like a dangerous version of Morris
day versus Prince and Purple Rain and
it's extremely annoying
and there's this unnecessary conflict
between future and wink Jesus can't
anyone chill in this movie besides is
Janine over there of course it's Janine
because God forbid there was a character
in this movie that isn't at this club
right now Jimmy Smith jr. hey boss we
should name Eminem's character like his
real name anything I like so long as
it's the most boring comment ever
Jimmy Smith jr. it is crap who told you
I said don't grab her excellent question
since apparently very few people have
actually heard a rabbit rabbit rabbit
man future answers this question so fast
it seems like he's been waiting forever
for someone to ask it I'm guessing the
only character trait they listed for
Alex was literally sex
kill shot shadowing well a free demo
free comes with a weight of BS Jimmy
weird this is exactly what the dude
behind the 7-eleven said when he gave me
that Pearl Jam CD in 1994 this
after-hours party conversation goes from
a girl got raped in an abandoned house
but I bet if it happened in a rich
neighborhood that have torn the house
down too let's burn that house down
ourselves extremely fast like there's
social equality conversations and then
there's arson they don't have to be
linked one that's on fire I'm no dream
killer but that doesn't sound like a
safe environment especially for kids
she rode to the after-hours party in his
car all her friends did then they all
car pulled here to burn down a house and
this is way before uber so I guess the
girls are all walking home tell me why
you left not only did this Janine
storyline have no reason to exist she
was at the club last night right she
couldn't talk to rabbit then everybody's
talking about it
are you froze up and got booed offstage
yeah but what about the time he got
chewed up and spit out and nobody talks
about when he kept rhymin and step right
in the next cipher a group of friends
and an old-ass beat-up car randomly
seeing a group of supposed foes then
stopping to get into an unnecessary
fight you cannot convince me that this
isn't a scene from Good Will Hunting
to get discography I could you ride to
work in the morning oh this car has been
an incredibly important plot point up
until now but they're just being
abandoning it because wink and the guy
from honey got into a fight also it was
everyone cool just sitting in the back
seat which was full of cheddar blood
just a few minutes ago Meg won't go down
on me call make it work also for what
it's worth he won't go down on me oh I
heard you liked rap battles so I put
some extra rap battles in your movie
about
rap battles speakin addresses take a
look at bought a fruitcake that's racist
okay folks
enough with the gay jokes thing Eminem
should have said to himself as a long
time ago
holy I've heard of groupies but this
lady is hornier than a three dick Rhyne
oh wow I haven't seen a sex scene this
unsexy involving a white rapper since
burn box no seriously this goes on for
sometime like far too sometimes also the
gal rapping said they had a 30-minute
lunch break and em joined that battle
after he made a purchase of the orange
juice at the truck where we were told
they had to stand in line
then he raps then he sneaks off with
this girl to a way back corner of the
warehouse and exactly how long or
Detroit minutes Wow Eminem would be
shockingly good at cinema since Breaking
and chattering you call him rabbit - I
gave him that nickname when he was
little he had buck teeth and big ears
God this woman is evil it's almost
enough to make me think the real-life
Eminem has mother issues
man witness the power of hope and denial
rabbit has plenty of evidence that wink
might be a scammer who is all talking no
real connections yet the promise of
rapping in front of a major player
brings forgiveness and a fucking hug
apology and then despite evidence that
this girl is a sex licker and her not
believable answers when questioned about
why she's hanging with wink rabbit
believes her obvious lies because he
wants to God did they use this movie in
classes at psychiatry school because
they can sure of how we have to stay
home tonight huh yeah should work on
some songs from our demo okay
Jesus this love story is the lamest I've
ever seen it's like Eminem and Brittany
Murphy met five minutes before they
filmed all their scenes together look at
he's King Lear notes they are random not
uniform and overstuffed I know he's poor
but he can't find more pieces of paper
does he literally only write couplets
does he never write lyrics line my line
all for the same song you're trying to
make him look mad genius but you just
ended up making him look mad but an
idiot she's got the ocean above the
clouds damn rabbit should have broken
his neck come here it's okay this movie
wants to portray rabbit as a better
caregiver to Lily than the mother and
maybe he's better than her but he still
fought twice in front of her that we
know of
he's half the reason she's panic
attacking under the table right now for
say so don't try giving him brownie
points just by having him coax her out
on a nice brother like assholes well I
told you not to sign me up character
says they're definitely not gonna do
something before inevitably doing that
thing cliche
also holy we have a protagonist fight
with each other
for the climax of the movie cliche on
the same scene a twofer also I get he's
stressed and outbursts happen but this
is not a lot future is clearly trying to
help rabbit be rabbit be rabbit be
rabbit everyone in this car has better
sexual chemistry with the Alex character
than her supposed love interest look is
it just me or does this movie have a lot
more scenes than people think I thought
I've seen this movie a lot but the only
thing I remember the rap battles the
factory the gross sex scene and future
saying DJ spin that a million times
maybe the bingo plays right now means
second half of this movie is 87 percent
mmm yelling at people
this has always bugged me wink and Alex
knew rabbit was going to come here
tonight but they still in an unlocked
room right next to the main studio like
this is intentional right yo what up
bitch let me see if I have this right
wait lied to rabbit and grabbed its
girlfriend rabbit beat him up a little
bit which may have even been kind of out
of line but then wink went to Papa Doc
and was like wow this girl and he
punched me and then these guys are now
gonna go gang beat him within an inch of
his life
either rap or Detroit is all the way up
if this is how it is in you right now
nobody can miss you and Papa Glock I'm
Your Mother
I want to make you something to eat
what's the big deal well the whole thing
about you guys hating each other and you
talking too much about your lack of
cunnilingus your emotional abuse and
neglect of Lily should keep going 3,200
what the high-stakes bingo game is this
it's $3,200 standard payout for bingo I
don't actually know if this seems
entirely too much money for a bingo win
you've been doing much better what
evidence have we been shown that rabbit
is doing better at the factory job he
was already apparently a cup and then
all we've seen is him goofing off at a
lunch truck becoming more obsessed with
music and oh yeah King Alex in the
factory and the worst sex scene since
well nine and a half weeks how is he not
been fired his boss finally caves and
accepts him and offered him extra shifts
which he accepts and for a hot second
it's a conflict in the story because
he's supposed to battle tonight but then
thankfully the gay factory worker he
defended in a rap battle the other day
ex maken is the situation over a shared
cigarette and rabbit is free when I say
goodbye
she had those pictures taken like today
right and that immediately sealed the
deal also she's headed to New York but
only after the congrat battle saving
that for something special studio time
you know for a movie about Eminem
rapping this movie features very little
of Eminem rapping talking about rapping
sure I'm about for real I know
surprising right I figured the only
person he can take out is the guy from
Pitt my ride
sure is so much so that I know ahead of
time I'm gonna struggle to find sins in
the next 20 minutes of this movie if
you're gonna set your boy up for success
don't you want him to come on later in
the night b-rabbit
who choked last week and will definitely
not choke tonight because this is the
climax and I've seen a movie before is
in the nasty bathroom stall considering
choking because the movie feels
compelled to build up cheap tension into
already legit tension Jesus Christ it
takes longer to get up on stage than a
winner at the Golden Globes he raps here
lookie how can six dicks beat pussies if
I ever get to take a meeting with the
heads of the major studios regarding
fair use and copyright this will be my
opening line look the last line about
walking his ass back across eight mile
and pulling his pants down was great but
objectively lickity-split won that
battle he went hard after a rabbit
covered a lot of ground rabbit just
insulted the free world crew and did a
couple nonsensical rhymes the sequence
is awesome for sure but it should have
been done before it got started no need
to show you the actual battle footage
let me sum it up after every fucking
rhyme look I know that futures trying to
stack the deck in his favor but can I
get a set up in this bitch about all the
obvious nepotism the leaders of the free
world may be assholes but they do
deserve a fair battle Jenner Bob
shadowing he literally spells out the
embarrassing rabbit is about to rap
about himself to take away Papa Doc's
best arrows cheddar X baba D there's
something here goddamnit
holy I've been waiting for this this
battle is awesome from the way rabbit
involves the crowd to the
self-deprecation to subverting Papa
Doc's insults it's goddamn magic and I
would absolutely remove three sins for
its awesomeness listen I wanted to do a
bonus round for all the times the future
said DJ spin that yearned for that bonus
round but ultimately there weren't
enough times to warrant it but viewer
know that I did count those
instances and I did it for you and also
there were ten of them damn this crowd
went sour on free world in a second this
is like the gladiator matches in ancient
Rome are you not entertained man out dog
gotta work I know they're all jacked up
on rabbits win but he won one king rap
battle man really expect him to retire
off that don't you start doing that no
you're gonna make the shed is the man he
needs a can surgically removed from his
hand
no good edges to my game boys it's not
you okay
Janine it's me I invented it's not you
it's me
all right